Yesterday, two key impeachment
witnesses tied President Trump
and Rudy Giuliani directly to
the quid pro quo with Ukraine,
and today we saw more fallout
from that bombshell.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yesterday,
we learned damning new facts
about the President's
direct involvement
in a scheme to extort Ukraine
to get them to manufacture dirt
on his political opponents,
and yet, today,
a few pundits and reporters
dismissed the first day
of impeachment hearings,
which included bombshell
new testimony
tieing Trump directly to the
scheme, calling them "boring."
One wrote that unlike
the best reality TV shows,
not to mention
the Trump presidency itself,
fireworks and explosive moments
were scarce.
And another wrote that the first
two witnesses called Wednesday
testified to Trump's scheme
but lacked the pizzazz necessary
to capture public attention.
What do you mean
it lacked pizzazz?
The only politicians
who have ever been entertaining
were the ones in "Hamilton."
What do you want them to do?
Show up with their own
backup dancers like
they're in a chorus line?
Or, better yet, maybe chairman
of the committee Adam Schiff
and the rest of the Democrats
can interpret the hearings
through the music of "Cats."
"Ambassador, do Jellicles
engage in quid pro quo?"
"Congressman, all I can say
is Jellicles can
and Jellicles do."
But the people
who are especially invested
in writing off the impeachment
hearings as a media spectacle
were of course Trump's defenders
in the Republican Party
and on Fox News,
who dismissed the entire thing
as a fake scandal
invented by Democrats for TV.
-What we will witness today
is a televised
theatrical performance
staged by the Democrats.
It seems you agreed,
witting or unwittingly,
to participate in a drama.
-Well, the Democrats' TV show
on impeachment
starts tomorrow morning.
-We read the transcript
from behind closed doors.
It's almost like
the pregame show.
Then all these people
fall into place
as if it was a Hollywood script.
-This is a television show.
It's all about trying to create
some kind of environment
and to create a spectacle.
Adam Schiff loves
television cameras.
I've never seen anyone
who would risk his life
to jump in front of one
like he does.
-You think Schiff
would risk his life
to jump in front of a camera?
Donald Trump is always on TV.
If Trump saw a camera
on the other side of a canyon,
he'd strap himself to a rocket
like Wile E. Coyote.
Now, you might remember
that before
the public hearings started,
Republicans complained
about the rules,
claiming that because Democrats
were holding
private, closed-door
depositions,
the process
was somehow illegitimate.
Well, Republicans got
their wish, and Democrats
held their first public
impeachment hearing yesterday,
and then Republicans
were completely satisfied
and they accepted the process
and never complained again.
-Well, they shouldn't be
having public hearings.
This is a hoax.
-So now you don't want
public hearings, either?!
Then what do you want? 'Cause
it's either public or private.
You gotta pick one. You can't
treat impeachment hearings
like a rookie cop
defusing a bomb.
"Cut the red wire?
No, the blue wire.
No, it's the red wire.
Wait! I got an idea!
Rudy, come sit on this bomb!"
[ Laughter ]
But now -- now we very much
are having public hearings,
and we learned something damning
from the first hearing
yesterday.
One of the witnesses,
Ambassador Bill Taylor,
revealed that a staffer
had overheard Trump
talking on the phone
with one of his key henchmen,
a guy named Gordon Sondland,
about the quid pro quo
with Ukraine.
-Taylor said a staffer of his
recently told him
about this conversation
involving the President
and the Trump donor
turned ambassador to the EU,
Gordon Sondland.
-In the presence of my staff
at a restaurant,
Ambassador Sondland
called President Trump
and told him
of his meetings in Kiev.
The member of my staff
could hear President Trump
on the phone
asking Ambassador Sondland
about the investigations.
-This was a cellphone,
I take it?
-It was a cellphone.
-The President must have been
speaking loud enough
for your staff member
to be able to overhear this?
-He was.
-That's right.
Trump was so loud,
people overheard him
on the other end of the call.
I'm shocked he didn't
just go all the way
and take the call
while he was on national TV.
"There was nothing illegal.
Oh, hold on. Let me take this.
Oh, good. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The extortion? Great.
And the bribery?
That's fantastic.
Should we -- Should we throw
another crime in there?
Maybe, like, fraud?
All right. Fantastic.
All right.
Gotta go. Press conference."
And then, today, the AP reported
that a second U.S. official
had also heard Trump's call
with Sondland,
and yet when Trump was asked
yesterday about that phone call,
he pretended he didn't know
anything about it.
-There was one moment
where Ambassador Bill Taylor
recounted a conversation
that an aide of his overheard
in which the aide says that he
overheard you say to Sondland,
"How are things going
with the proceeding
with the investigations?"
Is that correct?
And can you fill in some more --
-I know nothing about that.
First time I've heard it.
-Do you recall having
a conversation with...
-I don't recall, no, not at all.
Not even a little bit.
-Oh, not even a little bit.
You know Trump is lying when
he goes overboard like that.
It's like if you asked someone,
"Did you rob that bank?"
Most people would say,
"Of course not."
Trump would say, "I've never
even been inside a bank.
I keep all my money
stuffed inside my coat.
That's why it always
looks like that.
It's my fortune. Packed in."
[ Applause ]
And yet even as Republicans
pretended to complain about
the supposed media spectacle
of impeachment hearings,
they were looking to get in
on the act themselves.
In fact, this week,
CNN reported that Rudy Giuliani
is considering re-entering
the impeachment fray
by launching a podcast
to provide impeachment analysis
of the public hearings
in the House of Representatives.
Okay, first of all,
you can't do a podcast on
impeachment hearings when you're
a key figure in those hearings.
That would be like a murderer
hosting an episode
of "Dateline."
"Tonight, I try to track down
my wife's killer,
and I try to get away."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, you can't do
a crime podcast
about an open-and-shut case.
There's nothing to investigate.
This whole thing would make for
the shortest episode
of "Serial" in history.
-"Hello. I'm Sarah Koenig.
On this episode,
my guest is Rudy Giuliani.
Rudy, did you do it?"
-Of course, I did!
-"This has been 'Serial.'"
Although, personally,
I have to say the weirdest thing
about this Rudy podcast story
for us
is that we accidentally
predicted it a few months ago
when we first covered
Rudy's attempts
to dig up dirt on Joe Biden
back in May.
The best thing about Rudy
is he just admits everything.
We probably wouldn't have needed
the Mueller Report
if we had just given Rudy
a podcast.
Oh, my God.
We're in Rudy's head, you guys!
It's like in a movie
when the FBI agent
has to start thinking
like the killer.
In fact,
to predict Rudy's next move,
I've been doing
the same things he does --
smoking cigars, reading my iPad,
and sitting on my own balls.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, I bet Rudy doing a
podcast would really help Trump
because if there's one thing
you can say about Rudy,
it's that he always makes
a convincing argument.
-We got an anonymous
whistleblower who says
that Donald Trump
did something wrong.
Donald Trump,
like Hunter Biden says,
I didn't do anything wrong.
This all should have stopped
when President Trump said,
"I didn't do anything wrong."
-Oh, is that
when it should have stopped?
When Trump said so?
That argument only works
with 5-year-olds.
"Clean your room."
"Why?"
"Because I said so."
"Damn it! You got me!"
Seriously,
is that your argument?
I have a hard time believing
Rudy has ever actually
tried a case in a courtroom.
"Your Honor, my client says
he didn't do it,
so I think we can all
go home now.
And on your way home,
check out my new podcast,
"My Client Did It,
and Here's How."
So the first day
of the impeachment hearings
directly tied
both Trump and Rudy
to the Ukraine scheme,
which underscores yet again
that Rudy is a central figure
in this whole thing.
In fact, two of his associates
who helped him dig up dirt
in Ukraine
have already been arrested.
Remember those two guys?
Lev and Igor?
Those are their real names,
although it's impossible to keep
track of which one is which.
They look like
they played the burglars
in the Ukrainian remake
of "Home Alone."
But we found out this week
that Trump had at least
ten separate interactions
with these guys,
which means Trump was lying
when he said he had no idea
who they were when they were
first arrested last month.
-Sir, what conversations
have you had
with Lev Parnas and Igor Fruman?
-I don't know those gentlemen.
-Oh, you don't know
those gentlemen?
Whenever an idiot like Trump
suddenly reverts
to 18th-century diction,
you know he's nervous.
It's as if your wife
confronted you about an affair,
and you were like,
"Janice? Why, I, uh, have never
had a pleasure of making
that gentlelady's acquaintance.
Despite what you might hear
from some in the media,
yesterday's impeachment hearing
provided damning new evidence,
making clear that Trump and Rudy
were both directly involved
in the Ukraine scheme.
Everyone should watch
these hearings
because they make clear
without a doubt
that Trump and Rudy
are not innocent.
-Not even a little bit.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪